hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Google Feud now in
the last video you watched me laugh like
an idiot and absolutely nothing for
about 6 minutes straight you decided
that that wasn't enough so you demanded
more well surprise surprise I'm an idiot
all the time so we're gonna play more
but this time we're not gonna just stick
to one category like an idiot we're
gonna go and deviate into other places
like questions which is also have good
stuff is it possible to suck your dick
ah god damn it I told myself I wasn't
gonna do this is it possible to clone
yourself is it possible to fly is it
possible to give birth to a genie oh do
I have to be to work at Starbucks how do
I have to be to work at YouTube
do I have to be to work at rent too damn
it everything tastes good bad like semen
so sir he had only 30 good everything
tastes like balls will my dog eat my
well my dog eat my cat will will my dog
eat my car will my dog eat my food well
my dog she's my pet ready my baby need
my dead body
Oh God do astronauts poop do astronauts
have sex what that's what I want to know
do astronauts to be damned is can I eat
my didn't I get this one ok my potato
can I eat my dog oh god no can I eat I
can't get my bed
Steve [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
can't heat mmm car damn it
sperm ah come on I was actually gonna
think that but I didn't want to go that
road why do adults have nipples why do
adults have belly buttons
why you adults have taxes ah is it
painful
is it people to put it is it painful to
be an idiot this is pitiful the DA do
you fish ever explore space ah man I'm
doing badly how to get rid of your in
norms mmm
how to get rid of your acne what can
dogs learn to fly musk and dog learn to
sit can dog learn drive car can dogs
learn to speak can dogs learn to feel
love damn it what happens when you mix
alcohol and bad decisions what happens
when you mix alcohol and excessive
masturbation is my bird oh god damn it I
don't know why that wasn't one of them
is my bird on fire is my bird gay what
it how is that one of them is my bird
jock [ __ ] is my pregnant I don't think
you understand birds how do you fake a
death a murderer on Orgazmo
what I guess everyone's just already
knows how to do that
what is the number four times I gave a
[ __ ] what happened markable I don't
[ __ ] know one day I woke up and get
really stupid and then I started making
YouTube videos
why is my boyfriend so non-existent
why is my boyfriend so Jax it guy
is there a auguste
jizz you're a lucky ball is it bad to be
Hitler is it bad to kill your family
when is a good time to master May can
you die from eating too much dick oh I
gotta stop I got a can you de ruining
too much food that's not can you die
from eating too much weed can you die
from eating too much food can you die
from eating too much there's such a
thing as an underground race of potato
people damn it we're gonna rise again to
Santa Claus have sleeves does Santa
Claus have yeah
why is my goldfish plotting against me
how much does it cost to buy a house a
car hey don't make it how much does it
cost you buy a desert star [ __ ] a star
why why am I
my afraid of the dark
where my afraid of spiders why am I
afraid of shadows why am i why am i
afraid
ah what am I afraid of why am I afraid
of mannequins [ __ ]
from what heads can babies fight to the
dead from what age can babies drive and
say he can't baby subscribe to markup hm
what the [ __ ] is a bumper is it ok to
swim bit of Goldblum I just don't trust
a guy like with you - god dammit I don't
know why this game makes me laugh so
much I don't know it's cuz I get this
unleash my stupidity and I have a lot of
it and I try to hold it in and it just
comes out in burger
ah ok so thank you everybody so much for
watching this is google feud I don't
know I don't know how more you want from
me I can't do more I can't do it
oh so thank you everybody so much for
watching you can see the other video if
you haven't seen it already I'll put in
the description or check out board non
stupid videos that I've done there
aren't many but they're out there trust
me somewhere somewhere out there so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye